she says it have
things that you're finding yourself
well one thing of course is just getting
more subscribers you actually be really
patient and you we do get impatient
about that and stuff but the other thing
is I like I think I run this up before
already brought this up but it's the
editing like it takes for like maybe
three hours or the download and that's
really annoying to me like icon and then
like I don't know how did the best
computer so it so when i'm downloading
that for three hours I can't do anything
else on my computer or l2 like bleach
out my computer so I act like you know
go do something else but like its really
annoying as the sticks are like three
hours to do it so i have to wait three
hours just for that thing to upload and
all that
um I don't we don't really use a camera
in our videos we you well first off the
person who taught me how to edit and all
that well first thing I did was I
learned it from videos and all that but
the main reason was because of my dad he
taught me how to edit in film and all
that and but I don't we don't really use
a camera like we don't you don't even
use a camera in any of our videos we use
something called a oh god oh capture
card it's something that like you're
gaming right it will capture the screen
of that game so like it will capture
what you're doing in the game yeah
that's what they use in roosterteeth
yeah that's a good it's like a device
that you could kind of like set up so
God loves in these tools using yeah if
your day mayor if you're a gamer it's
like it's an HDPVR you're gonna use that
for gaming if you're gonna do videos for
you